- [Voiceover] The result
that I hope to show you,
or you give you an
intuition for, in this video
is something that we will use
in the proof of the chain rule,
or in a proof of the chain rule actually.
We may do more than
proof of the chain rule.
But the result we're gonna look at
is if we have some function u
which is a function of x,
and we know that it is continuous
at x equals c,
so if we know this, then
that's going to imply
that the change in u goes
to zero as our change in x in this region
around c goes to zero.
This is what I want to
get an intuition for.
That if u is continuous at c,
then as our change in x around c
gets smaller, and smaller, and smaller
as it approaches zero,
then our change in u
approaches zero as well.
To think about this, or
to even kind of prove it
to ourselves a little bit more rigorously,
let's think about what it means
to be continuous at x equals c.
Well the definition of continuity is,
so this literally is
the same thing as saying
that the limit as x approaches c
of u of x is equal to u of c.
The limit that our function approaches
as x approaches c is equal
to the value of the function at c.
We don't have a point discontinuity
or a jump discontinuity.
If we had a jump discontinuity,
then the limit wouldn't exist,
and we've seen that in previous videos.
Now I'm just gonna
manipulate this algebraically
so it essentially gives us this conclusion
right over here.
So this we can rewrite.
It's important to realize that u of c,
this is just going to be some value.
It looks like maybe this is a function
of x or something, but no,
this is just going to be some value.
I've inputted c here and I've evaluated
the function of that, and so this is going
to be some number.
It could be five, or seven, or pi,
or negative one, but it's just going
to be some value, some constant.
So I can treat it like a constant.
So this is going to be the same thing
as saying the limit as x
approaches c of u of x
minus u of c
is equal to zero.
And actually, in the video where we prove
that differentiability implies continuity,
we started with this and we proved
that right over there.
We show that these two
are equivalent things.
But hopefully you could even think
about the intuition.
This is just if the limit of u of x
is x approaches c is equal to this,
then when you evaluate this limit,
the limit is x approaches c,
well this thing is going
to approach u of c,
because we saw it right up here,
u of c minus u of c is indeed
going to be equal to zero.
So hopefully you don't
feel like it's too much
of a stretch, and you can just subtract
u of c from both sides
and apply properties
of limits, and you can
get this result as well.
But this is interesting
because this essentially
can take us to this,
the idea that as our change in x
gets smaller, and smaller, and smaller
as it approaches zero, then our change
in our function is also
going to approach zero.
Now let's just graph
this or visualize this
to get a sense of that.
So this is our x axis.
Woops.
That's our x axis.
Let's call that our u axis maybe.
And I did u intentionally because
that's the variable we'll use
in our proof of the chain rule video.
Let's say this right over here
is our function.
Let's say this right over here,
that is c.
This right over here is u of c.
U of c.
Then let's just take some
arbitrary x over here.
So some arbitrary x,
and then this right over here is u of x.
So if we define our change,
let me do this.
If we define our change in u is equal
to u of x minus u of c,
which makes sense because this
is our change in u.
So let's say this is going to be u of x
minus u of c.
If we define our change in x
is equal to x minus c,
which it is in this case,
it is x minus c,
then we can rewrite this limit
right over here.
Instead of saying the
limit as x approaches c,
we could write the limit as delta x
approaches zero, because
if x approaches c,
then delta x is going to approach zero.
So we could write this the limit
as delta x approaches zero of delta u
is going to be equal to zero.
We define this as our change in u,
and it is our change in u.
So this is equal to zero.
So another way of thinking about this
is as delta x approaches zero,
our change in u, our
change in the function,
is going to approach zero.
So as delta x approaches zero,
delta u approaches zero.
That's what we wrote over here.
Delta u approaches zero
as delta x approaches zero.
In a lot of ways, this is
hopefully common sense.
We're dealing with a continuous function.
As you get smaller and smaller,
and you can just think of it this way,
as you get smaller and
smaller changes in x's,
as our change in x gets smaller,
and smaller, and smaller, and smaller,
well it's because it's continuous.
You wouldn't be able to say this
for a discontinuous function,
but because it's continuous,
or you wouldn't be able to say this
for some discontinuous functions,
as our change in x gets smaller,
and smaller, and smaller,
then our change in u is
going to get smaller,
and smaller, and smaller.
So it makes intuitive sense,
but hopefully this makes you feel
even better about it
because we're going to use
this idea to prove the chain rule
in the next video.